Today I'm going to cover
primarily preference
optimization.
And I think Alvaro is going
to cover some things related
to reasoning.
So let's get started.
I guess the one clear trend
in the last 5 to 10 years
has been that we've
been like building
larger and larger
models, and we've
been putting far more
compute into them.
This is like an ever
very consistent trend.
And if you're familiar with-- or
if you've-- some people are even
making predictions
about AGI 2027,
and they are predicting that
we're going to keep putting more
and more floating-point
operations into these models.
But the question today
we're going to try to answer
is, how do we get from these
large language models, which
are pretrained to
predict text and get
these really nice
chatbots that some of them
you might have used.
So I'm going to very
briefly talk about--
this is not an NLP course,
and you should probably
take one if you're
interested in learning more
about pre-training.
It's a very, very deep topic.
But I'm going to
quickly touch upon what
we learn in pre-training and
why that doesn't necessarily
translate into the kind
of chatbots we use.
So in pretraining
large language models,
they're trained on
these gigantic corpus
of internet texts.
And the way they're
trained is roughly
predicting what the next word or
the next token in the sentence
is going to be.
So, for example, if
you have a sentence,
Stanford University is
located in blank, California.
So the model will learn to
predict what this text is.
And you can imagine.
Then you're learning
to predict this text.
You're learning a lot of facts.
You're learning a lot of trivia.
But you're also starting
to learn something
about the syntax of
how language operates.
And we can look at many
different examples here.
I went to the kitchen
to make some tea.
Standing next to Iroh,
Zuko pondered his destiny.
Zuko left the-- so yeah.
The model will learn to predict
the next token, which implicitly
requires it to know some facts,
know syntax, and also maybe
even reason about what
word should come next.
While this may like predicting
next token, you learn language,
but predicting next token
ends up learning a lot more.
And there's some
evidence that it ends up
learning some notion of
how the world operates.
So this is a very
nice example where
we ask the model to predict
the next set of tokens.
And here, the example is,
Pat watches a demonstration
of a bowling ball
and a leaf being
dropped at the same time
in a vacuum chamber.
Pat, who is a
physicist, predicts
that another model is asked to
predict the next set of tokens
or the next set of words here.
And to predict these
next set of words,
you implicitly have to
understand what the text was.
And in some way, you
have to understand
how the world operates as
well to be able to answer.
And it's very interesting.
If you change the prompt, you'll
get a different behavior out
of the model as well.
The point here being that
language models don't just
learn syntax, don't
just learn words,
but they learn a lot more about
how the world operates as well.
And similarly, we can ask
them to do math questions.
We can ask them
to generate code.
We can ask them-- they
have fairly reasonable
medical understanding as well.
And more importantly, we can
start transforming these models
into assistants now.
So the question now we'll
get back to is like,
OK, pre-training
gave us all that.
So how do we actually
make this into assistants?
So today's lecture, we'll try to
cover roughly two or three kinds
of techniques to do so.
First is instruction
fine tuning.
Second is RLHF.
And third is DPO.
And then we'll talk
about some limitations
about what is missing, where
are we going wrong, and so on.
All right.
So the first thing to understand
is when we pretrain models,
we're modeling language.
And yes, that learns
more than language.
It learns something
about the world.
But that's still not
equivalent to assisting users.
So this is an example from
GPT-3, where the prompt says,
explain the moon landing to a
six-year-old in a few sentences.
And the model
completes it with what
it thinks should be
the next set of tokens
according to the distribution of
text it has seen in its corpus.
So it starts off, explain
the theory of gravity
to a six-year-old.
Explain the theory of
relativity to a six-year-old
in a few sentences.
And this isn't like--
this is not what I expect
my assistant to do.
It's just a language model
predicting the next token.
What we do want it
to do is actually
give an explanation or
a story where it like,
a giant rocket ship blasted off
the Earth carrying astronauts
to the moon.
So some kind of an
explanation, which
was the original
intent of the question,
and not just the text that
has seen on the internet.
And that's where the discrepancy
arises between language modeling
and assisting users.
The first set of techniques
that were developed for this
was fine-tuning.
And we're going to talk
a little bit about this.
So the general paradigm,
even to this date,
has been to first
pretrain a language model
on a large corpus of
text and then fine-tune
for your specific task.
So how does fine-tuning work?
You collect a set of inputs, and
you have some target outputs.
And then you improve
the log likelihood
of these target outputs.
So in this step two,
you have this input
which was, the movie was
something, something.
And then you have some target
output, which is good or bad.
And the model learns to
predict whether the output was
good or bad.
And that's really the main
difference between fine-tuning
and pre-training.
As we realize--
I mean, these pre-trained models
are good for many more things.
We started scaling up the number
of tasks we can fine-tune on.
So the previous
example was maybe
something like
sentiment prediction.
But really, these
models can be fine-tuned
for many, many different
tasks at the same time.
So broadly, this can be seen as
collecting a set of instruction
and output pairs.
So for example, if the
instruction is, please
answer the following question.
What is the boiling
point of nitrogen?
we'll have some answer
like minus 320.4.
And we want to be able to
predict this answer conditioned
on the input.
And once we collect a corpus of
such instruction output pairs,
we can then evaluate them
on many, many unseen tasks.
Can Geoffrey Hinton
have a conversation
with George Washington?
Give the rationale
before answering.
And the model will produce
a reasonable output here.
So what if we fine-tune
different scale language models
on the same kind of corpus?
So one thing that was observed
in a lot of prior work
is that as you increase
the model parameter size,
they actually start
generalizing a lot better.
So even taking a very small
corpus of such instruction
output data sets,
you start seeing
a lot more generalization.
So to explain the
table a little bit,
the BIG-bench and MMLU are
like question-answer pairs
of the kind you just saw
in the previous slide.
And one thing to note here is
that the bigger the parameters
or larger the model is,
the larger the gain is
after instruction fine-tuning.
So what this suggest to us is
that the models start responding
and generalizing to questions,
even with very small corpus
of data as well.
So to give an example of what
the models look before and after
instruction fine-tuning--
it's a fairly simple question.
In the following sentences,
explain the antecedent
to the pronoun and state
that it is ambiguous.
So you get something
which represents more
like the raw language model,
which will start generating
text on the right side.
The reporter and the chef will
discuss their favorite dishes
and so on.
But after instruction
fine-tuning,
it will give us what
the user perhaps
intended from the
question, which
is to give the correct answer.
Cool.
So instruction fine-tuning
is fairly simple.
There is nothing very
complicated going on here.
So I'll take a second.
Do you see--
just reflect for yourself.
Do you see some limitations
to something like this?
One limitation that
obviously comes up
is that it's expensive
to collect such data.
You have to collect
questions and the labels
for those questions.
And that's hard.
As you start increasing the
hardness of the questions,
there's very few people who
can answer those questions.
So it's expensive to scale
such data collections where
the humans have to sit
down and write down
the answer to every question.
But then if you
look beyond that,
there are certain tasks which
don't even have a right answer.
So if I-- and this
is a lot of the use
cases of language models.
A lot of the use cases of
language models are creative.
So if I ask a language
model to write a story
about a dog and her
pet grasshopper,
there's no right
answer for this.
I cannot sit down and say, oh,
this is the exact story I want
to hear every single time a
person asks this question.
The second point
is a little subtle,
but in instruction fine-tuning,
we have a predefined answer.
So the mistakes are
penalized equally.
So there's no good
or right answer.
We're not necessarily saying
that this was the mistake.
We are basically saying
your entire answer is wrong
or your entire
answer is correct,
which is often not necessarily
true for a specific question.
So this is an example of this.
If we have a statement like,
Avatar is a fantasy TV show,
it's not that the
sentence entirely
is correct or incorrect, but
it would have been better
to describe the Avatar
as an adventure TV show
rather than a fantasy TV show.
I think this is like a problem
that has emerged recently,
is that the language models
truly are better at generating
answers than humans.
So if we rely on humans
to generate the answers
and generate the labels
for our questions,
we are going to be limited
by how good the humans can
answer the question.
And finally, one big mismatch
is that LLM objectives--
there's a bit of a
misalignment between what
we want our models to do,
which is to engage well
with humans, which is to--
and which is to
follow their intent.
Whereas our fine-tuning
objective basically says
predict this answer really well.
So there's a little bit of
a mismatch in our training
objective when we are doing
instruction fine-tuning.
Cool.
So this leads us to the paradigm
of reinforcement learning
from human preferences.
So the question is that,
how much of the improvement
from instruction fine-tuning
comes from following a format
or actually teaching
some new knowledge?
I think most of the work
suggests that it actually
is teaching largely formatting.
And most of the
knowledge actually
comes from the base
language model itself.
And there's a very
clear way to do this.
You can experiment
this by just training
the model wrong answers.
And it still does quite well
on the downstream tasks.
So it tells us
that it's actually
teaching formatting more
than the knowledge itself.
The question was, are
the corpuses always
question-answer format?
Because that's what we
want out of chatbots.
Not anymore.
I think this was very early
days of LLM fine-tuning,
and we were focused more
on question answering.
But the corpus for
instruction fine-tuning
are very, very diverse now.
These LLMs are used for a wide
variety of tasks, function
calling tools.
And it's not just assist--
assistance means many
different things.
It's not question-answers.
It could be just anything.
Great.
So now we'll get into
reinforcement learning
from human preferences,
which addresses
some of the limitations
which we discussed here.
So throughout this
section, we'll
use summarization as an example,
because there's not necessarily
a good summary that
we can often train on.
And for notation,
we'll assume that we
are given an instruction
x and the language model
will generate some sample y.
And we'll pretend that
we have a way for a human
to give us some kind of a
reward score for a given
summary conditioned on
some input x and summary y.
So we have some
news article which
is San Francisco, California.
Magnitude of 4.2 earthquake
shook the San Francisco
blah, blah, blah.
And we have one
summary, which is,
earthquake hit San Francisco.
There was a minor property
damage but no injuries.
And we have another one, which
is, Bay Area has good weather,
but it is prone to
earthquakes and wildfires.
Clearly, one of the summaries is
a little better than the other.
So let's say like our
reward function gives us
a score of 8.0, and the other
summary gets a score of 1.2.
Roughly speaking, you want
to set up the objective such
that we want to maximize
the expected reward.
So conditioned on some
input instruction x,
we want our language model
to generate summaries y such
that the expected
reward will be high.
Fairly simple standard RL
objective that you've probably
seen in the class before.
And this is like the core
of how chatbots are trained.
And the rough pipeline looks
as the following, which
is from the
InstructGPT paper, is
that we'll first do some
instruction fine-tuning.
This is we collect some
demonstration data to condition
like just to get the formatting
right as we discussed earlier.
Second step and the third step,
which will go a lot more into,
is to set up how to first get
a reward model, which allows
us to align with human intent.
And then we maximize
the reward model.
So these are the three
steps we typically follow.
Great.
So let's just pretend for now
that we have a reward model
where we want to maximize this.
And yeah, I'm
presuming you all are
familiar with this
gradient descent idea.
So, yeah, the way we would
change the LLM parameters
to maximize this
is something you've
seen before, like some
form of gradient descent.
Usually, there's more
complicated optimizers,
but we can pretend that
is not required right now.
For now, we'll just assume
like a generic RL formulation
where we are generating
some sample S hat.
So for some
distribution p theta S,
we want to change the
parameter's theta such
that the sample's S hat are high
reward under the reward function
r.
So the main issue is--
and this is why we do RL,
is our reward functions are
often nondifferentiable.
So if you ask me
to give a number,
my human mind is
nondifferentiable.
So we cannot backpropagate
through them.
So this is why we resort to RL.
So this is where
policy gradient methods
that I think Chelsea has covered
very early in the course come
in, is that they
allow us to maximize
nondifferentiable
reward functions.
And we can estimate and
optimize this objective.
And I'll do a brief recap
here because it's important.
And we'll slowly lead into
the RLHF pipeline as well.
But I presume you
have seen this before.
Great.
So in this generic objective
when we want to estimate,
the quantity that we want is the
gradient of the expected reward,
where we want the sample's S hat
to have a high reward under R.
So this can be written down.
This is just algebra at this
point, where the expectation can
be written down as the summation
of R(s) multiplied by p theta S.
And we have the gradient here.
So this is just a
definition of expectation.
And now we're going to propagate
the gradient forward simply
by linearity of the gradient.
I assume you have seen this,
but I'm going to go over this.
But this is a log
derivative trick,
which is we can rewrite
the gradient of p theta
as p theta times
gradient of log p theta.
So to see that, this is
simply from the chain rule,
is that the gradient
of log p theta
simply can be written as 1 by
p theta and gradient multiplied
by gradient of p theta.
Cool.
So we can rewrite this to
get this identity, where
the gradient of p theta
can be rewritten as p
theta gradient log p theta.
Cool.
So the quantities in yellow is
what we want to substitute back.
And if we plug this
back in, we get
the following equation, which
is reward of gradient of p theta
is the same as
expectation under p theta
R gradient of log p theta.
All right.
So why did we do all this?
Typically, when we're computing
expectation over sentences,
it's really not
possible to enumerate
every single sentence possible.
It's just simply intractable
to even try to do that.
So you want to be able to
estimate the gradient somehow.
And we want to be able
to create some kind
of a stochastic
estimator so that we
can get the gradient out.
So this log derivative
trick is what
allows us to take this
gradient and convert it
into an expectation, which we
can sample and then approximate.
And this is what we get as a
final result, is that it's again
an expectation of
a reward multiplied
by gradient of log p theta.
So the question is, do we take
this gradient because we cannot
backpropagate correctly?
There's two reasons, really.
First is we cannot set up an
objective where the reward--
we cannot assume the
reward is differentiable.
Second, which is the more
precise mathematical answer,
is that we are--
our parameters are
in the expectation.
So we do need to figure out a
way to take the gradients back
to the parameters in
the expectation as well.
Yeah.
But if our rewards
were differentiable,
we don't necessarily need to
set our optimization objective
like this.
We could imagine other
optimization objectives
where we directly
backpropagate end to end.
OK, so, yeah.
So we went through
all the math just
to show that we can
rewrite the gradient
of our original objective.
And we can rewrite
it as an expectation
again, which we can now
approximate using Monte Carlo
estimates, which is the
equation on the end.
And we can take this
approximate gradient
and plug it into our
favorite optimizer which uses
gradient descent or ascent.
And that's really like--
this is just supposed to
be a brief recap, so yeah.
And it's a very intuitive
objective as well.
So really, all it's saying is
that if for a certain sample
the reward is high, we should
increase the log likelihood.
So the parameters are
taking the gradient
in the direction of samples
which score high on the reward.
And that's really all
this objective says.
And if it's bad,
you take directions
opposite to those samples.
Cool.
And yeah, this is why
we call it reinforcement
learning because we're
doing good actions go there.
Bad actions don't go there.
The question is, am I drawing
full sentences or tokens?
In this context, we'll be
drawing full sentences.
Yeah.
The notation was
set up generally,
so we'll go back to
the xy notation again.
But that was just supposed to
be a brief primer on policy
gradients.
Cool.
So first problem is
that we have so far
assumed that we have some
kind of a reward function
which will tell us like,
hey, the summary is 10.0.
The other is 5.0.
That usually is not possible.
Let's say you're
training like the biggest
and the greatest LLM possible.
And it needs like
millions of such queries.
And you're not going to
have a human army sit there
and label every answer.
So it's not very scalable
to ask humans directly.
So the general solution
towards this end
has been to make preference
learning a separate optimization
problem, where we try to
figure out a human reward
model before starting
our RL optimization.
So, yeah.
So we had two summaries.
And we presented.
The score was 8.0 and 1.2.
And we'll try to train
on some kind of data
where we try to predict
the score so that we
have a learned reward
function, which we can later
use in the RL.
OK.
So we talked about we want
to learn this reward model.
And we have some
summaries where we
want to be able to
predict their score.
So how do we get these scores?
So we need some kind of
an annotated data set.
Now the issue is that if we
ask humans for scores directly,
two different humans
have completely different
calibration.
So for a summary
that has a score of 7
would mean something completely
differently to two humans.
So there's not really an
easy way to aggregate.
And even for the
same human, they
would probably score the
same summary differently
at different points,
depending on what they
ate for lunch or something.
So it's not really easy to get
a score directly from humans.
And if you ask them directly,
it doesn't work out very well.
The reward models
you learn are not
very useful for training
such language models.
So the solution to this is
to not actually ask them
for a score, but to actually
ask them for preferences.
So we give them few summaries,
and we just ask them, hey,
do you prefer this summary
over this summary or not?
And this is the kind of
annotated data set we should
expect to collect for humans.
So now going a little
bit deeper into this,
so we are going to collect a
data set of the form where we're
given, some kind of an input x.
And we're going to be given some
kind of a winning summary, which
is yw.
And we're going to be given some
kind of a losing summary, y L.
And we're going to have
some data set D for this.
And what we want to do
is train a reward model
which assigns a higher score
to the winning summaries
and assigns a lower score
to the losing summaries.
So the optimization
objective, which
is called the
Bradley-Terry objective,
is a way of going from such
data set of preferences
to an implicit reward
score, which would
align with the preferences.
And the way we train this is
we minimize this log sigmoid.
And the difference of reward
is assigned to the winning
and the losing summary.
So, yeah, all this
objective is saying
is that a reward
model should make
sure the reward for
the correct summary
is higher than the reward
of the losing summary.
So the question is
like, is it unbounded,
or do you normalize this?
The actual issue that
arises, which is-- this
is actually a very
important observation
that we'll actually use
to develop DPO as well.
The objective just asks
the difference to be high.
So the difference will be high
even if you assign a reward
of 1,000 and 10,000.
Or it'll be high even if
you assign a difference
from 1 to 999.
There's no real scaling
here which allows that.
So, yeah, typically,
you have to do
some kind of post
hoc normalization
to make sure that different
prompts get rewards
at the same scale.
Otherwise, the
optimization objective
can get a little wonky.
But yeah, this is the
Bradley-Terry objective,
which allows us to go from
a data set of preferences
to a reward model which
we'll use in our lecture.
Yeah, the question is, is
that why we take the sigmoid?
Not really.
There's a few different
functions you can set up.
Sigmoid just maps
naturally to like, oh,
the probability of this sample
winning over this sample.
So, yeah, that's why it's
typically used as a sigmoid.
But really, all we
want to encourage
is that the reward
model should--
the difference should be high.
All right.
So now we get back
to our RL loop.
And what do we have?
We have some kind of an
instruction fine-tuned model,
let's say, p PT.
We have learned some kind
of a reward model using
the Bradley-Terry objective,
which gives us a scalar output.
So it takes an input,
x, gives us a summary,
and then gives us a scalar
output, RM phi x comma y.
OK, so this is the simple part.
In some ways, we're going
to do the RLHF loop here.
And the way we're
going to do this is we
want to optimize the expected
reward as we started with,
where we're going to plug
in our LLM parameters
in the expectation for p theta.
So it will produce some kind of
a summary, y hat, conditioned
on some input, x.
And our reward model is going
to be the learned reward
model from preferences.
Before I move on, I have a
question which is slightly hard.
I started off saying that
the reward functions are not
differentiable.
And that's part of
why we want to do RL.
But we just learned
a reward model.
And we know--
we typically learn
a reward model using
neural networks themselves.
And they are very
much differentiable.
We can do backpropagate
through them.
So why are we doing RL?
[INAUDIBLE]
That's the right answer.
So the token-- like we're
outputting discrete tokens.
And when we assume we
can backpropagate things,
we cannot actually backpropagate
through the discrete language
tokens.
So even if we have a reward
model that is differentiable,
we generate some output.
We plug it into
our reward model.
And then we want
to go back directly
to the parameters of
the language model.
But we get this discrete
bottleneck in the middle,
where we cannot backpropagate
our gradients from the reward
model to the language model.
And that's the reason why we
again have to resort to RL,
even though we have a
differentiable non-black box
reward model here.
But yeah, good
attempts, everyone.
These are close.
Yeah.
So let's say like
we have a reward
model, RM phi x comma y hat.
Let's assume like y is
a continuous variable.
So typically, we'll
take some input.
We'll generate some output.
We'll plug it into our
learn reward model.
And if everything is a
continuous function here,
you can rely on backpropagation
to take the gradients
and update the model parameters
such that the reward model
score keeps going up.
So you don't actually
need to do RL.
And not doing RL
is often very good
because it's expensive to
do because of the sampling.
But the issue is that our y
hat here are discrete tokens.
So they're sampled from some
underlying distribution.
And once you include
the sampling operation,
it's very hard to--
there are tricks to do that,
but they're not very stable.
But it's hard to
backpropagate through that.
Yes.
So I didn't want to
assume like Gumbel-SoftMax
is known to people here,
but Gumbel-SoftMax,
unfortunately, so far hasn't
scaled super well, especially
now the language-- so
to contextualize this,
y hat is a sentence
which could be thousands
and thousands of tokens.
And each token
vocabulary sizes are
on the order of hundreds
of thousands of tokens.
So yeah, the entire sentence is
a combinatorial space of like
100,000 tokens multiplied
by the sequence length.
Gumbel-SoftMax usually doesn't
scale beyond thousand dimensions
or so on.
Yeah.
Cool.
This is a hard
question, so I wanted
to touch upon this
because you should never
assume that you need to do RL.
So yeah.
All right.
So one issue, even when
we set up this objective,
is that-- and somebody
alluded to this,
was that our reward
models are never perfect.
So we don't want to assume that
they'll give us a perfect score.
After all, they
have been like fit
to human preferences on
a certain distribution.
We don't want to
assume that they'll
give us a good score for
every single input and output.
And if you do Naive optimization
like we described so far,
you will get models which
have the reward model.
And you'll see some plots
for that later as well.
So one another thing
we add is something
called the KL penalty or the
Kullback-Leibler divergence.
And what the KL penalty
basically says is--
so it's added to the reward,
where we have beta log p
theta by p pre-trained.
So p theta is the quantity
we are optimizing right now.
This is the language
model, which
is currently assigning the
probabilities to token y hat.
And p pre-trained is the
model we started with.
So it could be
instruction fine-tuned.
And these are the probabilities
under those model.
And roughly speaking, whenever
a probability distribution
deviates from the pre-trained
distribution, we get a penalty.
So we get a lower score if
we are deviating too much
from the pre-trained model.
And if you work out
the math, this thing
is exactly the KL divergence
between our distribution
or our language model that
we are optimizing right now,
and the language
model we started with.
And the reason why we want to
do this is that, as I said,
the reward model is imperfect.
We know it's more accurate on
a distribution of preferences
that we trained on,
and we want to make
sure the model stays close
to where it started off from.
So this is one of the
first examples of RLHF
where it worked quite well.
So this is a
summarization task itself.
And the curve basically--
the x-axis is the model size.
And the y-axis is, how
often is the summary
preferred over some ground truth
summary for some news articles.
And if you look
at the blue curve,
it's the pre-training
curve, which
as the model size increases,
the fraction of summaries
preferred over the
baseline increases.
And then you have SFT or
instruction fine-tuning,
which gives an improvement
over the pre-trained model.
But when you look
at the RL curve,
this is the first model
which actually exceeds
the human written summaries.
So now we are generating
summaries even
at a small size, which are
preferred over human summaries.
And this is one of the
earlier results in RLHF
which shows the
power of optimizing
for preferences directly.
So the question is
like, are there models
for human preferences
which are not just binary
and account for fuzzy?
I think this is a very hard
question, which goes into--
so it is known that human
preferences can often
be intransitive.
So what do I mean by that?
Let's say we prefer A over
B. Then we prefer B over C.
And then we prefer C over A.
This doesn't make any sense,
because ideally, if you
prefer A over B and B over C,
you should prefer
A over C. But we
get lots of scenarios where
humans prefer A over C as well.
And you will, unfortunately,
observe some noise in the data
like that where the
preference is-- in fact,
the preferences we observe in
real life are very, very noisy.
And I don't think we have
a great solution for this.
To even ground this,
preference learning
is a binary classification task.
We're just trying to predict
which sample is winning.
So it's a binary
classification task.
So most binary
classification, you
can reach an accuracy
of like 90%, 95%.
But for most of our language
model and reward models,
we reach an accuracy
of like 65% to 70%.
So we're barely doing
better than chance.
But even that is
still like enough
to give us pretty large
improvements in performance.
The question is
like, what changed
to make this differentiable?
We did not make
anything differentiable.
That's the reason why
we started doing RL,
is to be able to take
the policy gradient.
This estimator, this does not
require us to be able to--
yeah.
So that just
requires the gradient
to be like with the log
probabilities of the model.
It does not backpropagate
into the reward at all.
So the question is like,
what if the p theta
RL is less than p theta PD?
And wouldn't that encourage the
model to go in those directions?
It's good to know.
So this is like-- the
expectation is broken down here
into more explicitly.
But it's good to know a
property about KL divergence
that it's always greater
than or equal to 0.
I'll leave that as an exercise
for you to prove that.
So the penalty is
always positive.
So the question is, are
there intelligent ways
to choose prompts such that
we get preferences over things
that the model is bad at?
That's a great question.
Yeah.
So there are works which
try to look into it.
This like touches upon
active exploration.
You want to get preference
signal explicitly
where the model is confused.
So I think there's
things which touch
upon we want to maximize
information gain such
that the model will
learn the best.
Is there a
well-established standard?
I don't think so.
But this is a good
problem to look into.
OK, I will start with direct
preference optimization next.
So there will be a little bit
more math, but it's very fun.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about direct preference
optimization.
So the RLHF pipeline
I described,
some of you might find it
complex, or some of you
might find it easy.
But in practice,
when we try to do
this at very large-scale models,
it can be quite expensive.
So let's say you're training a
hundred billion parameter model,
maybe a trillion
parameter model.
You have to sample every
answer and then query
your reward model.
And depending on the
RL algorithm you use,
you have to compute like value
functions and other things just
to optimize the model.
And you don't have to
understand this figure.
I put it specifically
to scare you guys.
So here, there's just
like a whole flow
of things that in practice can
be fairly hard to get right.
And the more parameters
you have in the system,
the harder it is
to get it right.
So RLHF can be
pretty complex, but--
so when we were looking into
direct preference optimization,
our goal was to like, can
we make this a lot simpler?
And yeah, as I said, they
have some initial pipeline
which we refer to as RM.
We take an
instruction-tuned model
and produce a final RLHF model.
But if you look at
the whole process,
we have a language
model, and we're
collecting some preferences.
Why can we just not directly
train on the preference data
and directly optimize
the parameter models?
Why do we have to learn
this intermediate quantities
like a reward model?
And why can't we just
directly go from preferences
and optimize our language model?
So that's really why it's called
direct preference optimization,
is that we find a way to
go from preferences, too,
and optimizing the
language model.
And the way we do it is
that at a very high level,
we want to be able to write
the reward model in terms
of our language model itself.
Why do we want to do that?
Because we fit our reward
model to the preference data
through a fairly
simple classification
loss, the Bradley-Terry
loss we discussed.
If we can just connect the
reward model and the language
model, instead of having
a separate process,
we can just take the
language model parameters
and fit it through
the loss directly.
And that's really the high level
motivation for direct preference
optimization.
Yeah.
So this part of the math gets
a little bit slightly intense.
So I'll go through this slowly.
OK.
So we discussed the
scale-constrained RL objective
in the last few
slides, where we want
to maximize the expected reward
with some KL penalty, such
that the model should not
drift away from the instruction
fine-tuned model a lot.
So again, the parameters we're
going to optimize is p theta RL.
p pre-trained and RM are fixed.
And for now, we can--
yeah, we're just assuming some
kind of a reward model here.
It turns out that
this equation actually
has a closed-form solution.
And this is not
possible if you're
doing just the regular
expected reward maximization.
But once you add
a KL constraint,
it turns out that you can write
out a closed-form solution
to this equation,
which is really cool.
It's rare to find such things.
And the solution looks
something like this.
This is the optimal
policy, p star,
where we're going to
compute probabilities
over y hat conditioned over x.
And roughly, this optimal
quantity says that we want--
ignore the Z (x) for now.
We have our pre-trained model,
p pre-trained y hat given x.
And we're going to multiply
the log probabilities
with the exponentiated reward.
So very simply,
put exponentiated--
so if a sentence has
a higher reward--
so if y hat has a
higher reward, we're
going to upgrade
the probabilities
under the optimal distribution
by an exponentiated reward
by beta.
High reward, high exponent,
higher probability
under the optimal policy.
If the reward is
low, it's going to be
downgraded by exponentiated
reward as well.
And Z (x) here is just
a normalizing factor
which ensures that this quantity
is a probability distribution.
So really, you only need
to focus on the numerator.
And that's it.
You'll have to
take my word for it
that this is the optimal
solution for the above equation.
Maybe I can share something
later on how to derive this.
But yeah.
Cool.
Now this is where the
key observation comes in,
is that because we have
this optimal solution
to the above equation,
we can rewrite the reward
model in terms of the
optimal policy itself.
So this lower equation is
just like a rearrangement
of the terms.
The reward model can--
RM (x comma y hat) can be
written as beta log p star
upon p PT.
And we have some
beta log Z (x) term,
which is a constant over y.
So again, just to make sure this
makes sense intuitively as well,
if a completion y hat
should have a high score,
it will typically have a
high probability under p star
as well.
And p PT is something
that's fixed,
so beta log will be
high whenever the reward
model gives a high score.
And similarly, if a reward model
assigns a poor score to y hat,
our optimal policy
will typically
assign a low
probability to y hat.
And typically, the beta log p
star by PT will also be low.
So the relationship
sort of makes sense.
And we can ignore Z (x) for now.
Cool.
The main argument here
is that this isn't just
true for the optimal policy.
You can always plug in
some reward model p theta.
And it will be optimal for
some kind of reward model.
And that's really like the
observation you make here.
And yeah, so we've
just replaced p star
with some kind of
a learnable policy,
given that our parameter's
theta represent
the optimal policy for some
kind of a reward model.
And after that is simple.
Given the relationship
we have derived so far,
we know this is how we
fit our reward model
through the Bradley-Terry loss.
We want to make
sure that the reward
for the winning
completion is higher
than the reward for
the losing completion.
And so far, I've been asking
you to ignore the partition
function, but that
was for a reason.
The reason is that
because the objective only
optimizes for the difference
between the rewards,
the partition function Z
(x) just simply cancels out.
So maybe I can write
this out on the board.
We started with the relation
RM theta x comma yw.
And we had beta log
p theta yw given
x, where yw is the winning
completion, and p PT yw given x.
Yeah.
So this is the relation we
used with beta log Z (x).
And we're going to
rewrite the same thing
for the losing
completion as well.
So x comma y L beta
log P of theta,
which is the current
parameters we're optimizing.
y L is our losing
completion conditioned
on the input x divided by
the p, the log probabilities
under the pre-trained model, y L
conditioned of x and beta log Z
(x).
Now notice that the
reward model is like--
the input is the same
to the reward model.
So we're using the
same text, and we're
summarizing the same text.
So the input is
actually the same.
So when we're going
to subtract this,
we're going to subtract
these and this.
And this is just simply
going to cancel out.
The reason why canceling
out of this is important
is that Z (x) is actually
intractable to compute.
It's not something we
can compute for real.
So we get this relation
that you can see over here,
is the difference between
the reward models is simply
the difference between
the beta log ratios here.
Cool.
So taking this identity
which we have just derived,
we simply plug it into the
original Bradley-Terry loss.
And we get something
super nice, is
that we will have a data set of,
again, input, winning output,
losing output.
And we're going to optimize
this objective directly
for the language
model parameters.
And this is a classification
objective, by the way.
So we're not doing
any RL loop anymore.
We are going directly from
the preference data set
and optimizing the language
parameter models themselves.
Yes.
So initially, it
will be the same,
but the gradient would
only backpropagate
through the P thetas.
p PT will remain
the same throughout,
and it will increase the
probability of the winning
completion and decrease
the probability
of the losing completion.
So let's spend a little
bit of time here again.
This objective will try
to encourage the RM theta
for the winning
completion to go up and RM
theta for the losing
completion to go down.
The way to increase RM theta is
to increase the probability of y
w under the current
model, and decrease
the probability of the losing
one under the current model.
It's a very intuitive objective.
Good thing go up.
Bad thing go down.
And apparently, you can do it
without RL or any complexity.
So the question is, can we do
something like distillation
instead of this?
The question is like,
so for the reward model,
you first have to get a
reward model somehow, right?
There's no easy way
to get it, so you
have to collect some
kind of preference data
to even begin with to
get a reward model.
And that's where
DPO comes in, is
that if you have collected
a preference data, instead
of fitting an
explicit reward model,
you can optimize your language
model parameters directly.
Yeah.
So the question is there's a
penalty for pre-trained model.
We're not drifting too far
from the pre-trained model.
Actually, this does do that.
So this is a good question.
So our loss function is
set up as a log sigmoid.
So one property of the sigmoid
is that the gradients vanish
when the difference becomes--
is already sufficiently large.
And the difference becomes
sufficiently large, like faster
than the--
so the beta parameter
actually controls how quickly
the difference becomes large.
So if you have a very high
beta, even a small discrepancy
would suddenly
saturate the sigmoid,
and it would not change
the parameters a lot.
The question is, is
the main advantage
of DPO that you don't have
to train a reward model?
The way I would
say it is that you
are training a reward
model, because you're
using the same objective.
The DPO provides a connection
between the reward model
and the corresponding
optimal policy for it.
So you don't have to do
an explicit or a loop
to go from the reward model
to an optimal policy for it.
You can all-- we have cleverly
parameterized a reward
model in terms of the
language model itself.
So when you fit a reward
model to the preference data,
you are optimizing the
language model itself too.
And so the question is, do we
still need to do RLHF or not,
given this is cheaper?
I think it depends
a lot on situation.
I think there's still some
purported benefits to RLHF
because you can expect like
some kind of generalization
from the reward model,
which allows you
to grade generations which might
not have been seen in preference
data.
So there's still
some benefit to it.
So it depends upon your budget
and what you want to achieve.
So the question I get is
that the KL divergence,
why are we relying
on the sigmoid
when initially the KL divergence
was not related to the sigmoid?
[INAUDIBLE]
To be more clear
or precise, I think
it's the beta term which
controls how fast, how much
you're allowed to drift away.
And even in the
original RL objective,
this beta term is what
controls the allowed divergence
between our current model
and the pre-trained model.
So if the beta is
really high, you
are not allowed to diverge
at all because you'll
be penalized a lot more.
Yes.
So the beta controls the
strength or the weight
on this divergence.
That's a good question.
Yeah.
So there's two kinds of
sampling involved right now.
First, we want to create a
preference data set where
humans label their preferences.
And then during
the RL optimization
itself, we want to
sample to get a score
under some kind of an external
or explicit reward model.
And then we score,
and then we optimize.
So we are taking care of
the second sampling step.
But the first sampling
step is still needed.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So when you're doing online RL
or some kind of RLHF procedure,
you don't only need the prompts.
You don't need a
preference data set.
So typically, the set of
prompts which is used during RL
is larger than the set
of prompts you used
during preference training.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So I think question
basically tries to ask,
can we take into account the
strength of the preference
and not just like
a binary label?
I think this is a limitation
for both RLHF and DPO, I think.
And we should-- so giving
more insight, typically,
when we collect
preference data sets,
we ask annotators to give a
strength for their preferences.
And we only keep the
preferences which are strong.
So typically the
preference-- but this
isn't a resolved problem.
How to learn from noisy data and
low preferences or high strength
preference's still
an unsolved problem.
And yeah, these are some of the
results for direct preference
optimization.
We showed like a
theoretical equivalence
between doing the DP objective
and doing a KL-constrained RL
procedure.
And in practice, when we try to
look at the summarization task
and try to measure win rates
like we were doing earlier,
we do actually find that
it does similar or better.
But this is like a
debatable question.
So, yeah.
But in general, it
does pretty well.
The beta parameter that--
do you see this
beta parameter here?
That corresponds exactly to
the beta parameter in the--
which is the extra
hyperparameter there.
So I'm just going to summarize
what we have learned so far.
And then we'll move on to where
things are missing and so on.
We want to optimize
for human preferences,
because first of all,
it's more aligned
with the objectives we want.
The way we use these
models are more closely
aligned with improving
human engagement
or satisfying human
preferences, so we
want to optimize for
that directly as well.
And instead of relying
on uncalibrated scores
from different
annotators, we try
to collect preferences
and then learn a reward
model of some form, either
through DPO or through RLHF,
and improve the
model through that.
In RLHF, we learn an
explicit reward model,
which gives an explicit score
for every completion we sample.
And we'll use that to optimize
the language model parameters.
And we typically impose
some kind of KL constraint
to make sure that our model
does not drift too far
from where it was initialized.
It's very effective, maybe
sometimes even more effective
than DPO.
But it can be a little
tricky to get right,
and it's computationally
expensive
because of the sampling
procedure that needs to be done.
And in direct
preference optimization,
we can completely
skip the sampling part
and optimize directly
on the preference data
by posing it as a binary
classification problem.
Cool.
And it's very
simple and effective
and does not require
an online step.
So where does this all lead us?
We've discussed all
the RLHF and DPO stuff.
And these are roughly how the
chatbots are built, by the way.
So this is the
InstructGPT pipeline.
This was one of the first
instruction, first chatbots
which was available to public.
And they interacted with it.
And it worked pretty well.
It can do a lot of tasks.
It can answer general
purpose questions.
And yeah, InstructGPT.
This is a comparison between
what the pre-trained model gives
as an answer versus what an
instruction even though an RLHF
model gives us an answer.
And yeah, these
are some examples.
And yeah, we have optimized
these models for dialogue.
And it's not just summaries.
I want to say we can optimize
them for many, many general
purpose tasks.
And the more data you
collect, more tasks you cover,
the better these
models are going to do,
the better they're going
to understand the intent,
and the better they're going
to respond to all of our needs.
And yeah, DPO has been used a
lot in the open-source community
ever since it was launched.
It's fairly cheap, works.
It's pretty performant.
And at some point, all LLMs were
using DPO to get their alignment
with human feedback.
Llama and Mistral models,
if you've heard of them,
were also post-trained
using DPO.
So, yeah.
And I guess this is an
interesting example where it's--
it's a good question
to ask, like what
is the difference between
instruction-tuned model and RLHF
models.
And one clear stylistic
difference that emerges
is that they tend to give
more detailed answers,
well-formatted
answers, and they tend
to align more with
the kind of text
that humans find easier to read.
So the question
here are like, what
are the five most common
causes of stress among people?
And if you just do
instruction fine-tuning
with a very small data
set, you get a good answer.
The five most common causes
of stress among people
are work, money, relationships,
health, and family.
But then you do some
kind of a PPO procedure.
You get a much
clearer, longer answer
with a very well-formatted list.
And these are all
emergent properties.
This is what the
model has discovered
that humans like and prefer.
And that's why they tend to
generate answers of that form.
I love the question.
I'll basically like--
I had a slide on
this towards the end.
But yes, the question is, can
we trust like people's feedback?
And what do we do if people
don't know what they want?
Again, that's a very
hard boundary to go to.
And I think what
happens is that there's
a misalignment between
short-term incentives
and long-term incentives.
There are certain behaviors
which look good in short term,
and people give feedback based
on short-term incentives.
But sometimes behaviors are--
these are very undesirable
in the long term.
And that is truly a hard
problem to solve within the RLHF
pipeline.
That's a good question.
The question is like, do
they rank like two answers
or multiple answers?
And do we train
on nC2 pairs or--
yeah.
So I think yeah, you
can roughly like--
just for efficiency
purposes, people typically
rank more than one answer.
And you get more
learning data out of it
that way because you get
nC2 preference pairs.
But you can-- there's something
called the Plackett-Luce family,
which is like a generalization
of Bradley-Terry that
allows you to directly train
on ranked completions as well,
beyond just
preference pairs too.
So you can do either of those.
They probably both work fine.
Yeah, that's a
really good question.
So are companies incentivized to
give preferences to engagement
which are not
aligned with human?
This goes well beyond the
scope of this lecture.
And be like, I don't know
what I can say about this.
But we can look back at history.
So this is not an issue
that was just true for LLMs.
For example, YouTube
had a lot of issues
with recommendation
systems, and people
were engaging with YouTube way
more than they wanted it to.
So in some ways, this
is a broader problem
on how technology
should be interfaced
with people and societies.
But if I briefly recall
from that incident,
is that it was actually in
YouTube's incentive to make sure
that the consumers have
long-term healthy engagement,
which means if
they're like spending
20 hours a day on YouTube,
that's probably not
good for the product as well.
So they probably want to
make sure that they're not
spending way too much time.
So if you do optimize
for long-term engagement,
that should ideally address--
that should not fall to
the sycophantic behaviors
that we saw from
GPT-4, because that
is more short-term behavior.
But yeah.
Cool.
And yeah, this is basically
all we've talked about.
And I wanted to bring up a
couple of things that this is--
let me just jump
ahead to the slide
where-- because we've
already talked about it,
is that this is a very
fast-evolving topic.
This is touching our
lives right now when
we are deciding how to
interface chatbots with humans.
And for people who might not
be familiar with this incident,
but GPT-4o became
fairly sycophantic
due to a model update
that was pushed.
And suddenly, it was like
endorsing all good and bad ideas
from their users in a way that
everyone deemed was unhealthy.
So I don't work at OpenAI, and
I'm not making any comments.
But these issues,
these are very real.
And we're still
trying to understand
how does our feedback data
affect our final model's
emergent behaviors.
And this affects how we
use our products as well.
And yeah, a lot of great
questions came up in the class.
And those are active problems
people are working on.
And we don't necessarily have
the answers to all of them.
So you guys should
go look more into it.
Yeah, and the other main thing
that I do wanted to touch upon,
which is the limitation
of the current paradigm,
is that there's this
phenomena of reward
hacking, which again touches
upon misalignment as well,
is that when we train on
these learned reward models,
they do align with
human preferences
up to a certain point.
But as you train
progressively against them,
they tend to start drifting
away from what we truly want.
So it's a very
common problem in RL
when you have proxy rewards
instead of true rewards
that you care about.
And this is generally true
for machine learning as well.
So yeah.
This affects our ability to
scale reinforcement learning,
too, because if
you start hacking,
you have to stop
training at some point.
And this is like an active
optimization problem
that people are
trying to address.
Yeah, I think the field
is evolving quite a lot.
So it goes beyond like--
people are moving towards
more rubric-based things,
where we score them for
several different aspects.
But yes, you typically do want
to collect many different kinds
of data to teach the model
what kind of behaviors
we want to instill and
what's the right way
to respond to
certain situations.
It's very hard to cover every
situation a chatbot might ever
encounter.
So we are relying on the model
to generalize from what kind
of data we're teaching.
But these things
break all the time,
and there are certain
unexpected behaviors
that come out of
these models in ways
where we could not anticipate.
Yeah, I've already touched
a little bit upon this,
but it's a very fast-evolving
field, very many, many areas
still to improve.
Preference data is still
expensive to collect.
And as we've maybe
discussed, it's
not necessarily representative
of what kind of model behaviors
we want.
So we are looking for better
ways to improve the feedback.
I think you listen to a lot more
about very cool, evolving things
in reasoning space,
where the models
are generating their
own outputs from
and are being graded
by verifiable rewards.
And that's one of
the coolest topics
we're looking at as well in
post-training and reasoning
as well.
And something that I personally
find very interesting
is that language
models are aligned
to the aggregate
preferences of humans.
But we are interacting
one on one.
We're not interacting
with the entire internet.
So we do want to
eventually make sure
that the models are aligned
to our needs and not
just everybody's needs.
So personalizing language models
and having more contextual input
about us and our preferences
is something that's also
a fairly nice evolving field.
And yeah, we talked a little
bit about hallucinations
and uncontrolled
emergent behaviors.
And these are all still
active problems we work on.
And that's all for today.